بين ليله وضحاها انقلبت حياتها بعد ان
كانت ايقونه
واصغر مليارديرا في العالم
في الساعه السادسه صباحا وان تشغل وظيفه
براتب اقل من 0.2
دولار يعني اقل يعني
الساعه الواحده تتشارك ايضا مرافق
الاستحمام في سجن جنوب تكساس هذه الفتاه
ستقضي احد عشر عاما من حياتها خلف القضبان
بعده ادانتها بتهم متعدده بينها الاحتيال
على المستثمرين خلال اداره شركه باريسون
لمنتجه لمنتجها المتعلق باختبار الدم
على فكره ملفته جدا عملوا كتير وثائقيات
افلام وثائقيه عن الموضوع وهي يعني الفكره
بحد ذاتها فعلا رائعه ولكن
بدنا نشوف هلا شو صار معها بالضبط لانه من
هي هذه الفتاه التي هومز مشاهدينا هذه
الديره الصغيره التي خدعتها العالم انشات
هومز شركه فيرانوس للتشخيص الطبي عام 2003
مروجه لاجهزه اعتبرت ثوريه وقادره بحسب
مدعت على اجراء اختبار طبي بالاستعانه
ببضع قطرات من الدم فقط وهي طريقه اسرع
وارخص من المختبرات التقليديه الطبيه بعد
سنوات من الدعايه الخادعه استطاعت شركه
جمع قرابه مليار دولار من المستثمرين
وانشاء مجلس اداره مؤثر يضم مسؤولين كبار
سابقين طبعا وصلت الشركه الى القمه
مشاهدينا في عام 2014 بقيمه تقديريه بلغت
في ذلك الوقت 9 مليارات دولار لتحصد وقتها
لقب اصغر مليارديرا عصاميه في العالم من
مجله ووردس
وخليفه ستيف جوبز من جهه اعلاميه اخرى
ايضا هذه الفضيحه انكشفت عندما كشفت صحيفه
وولز جورنال ان الجهاز الموعود من الشركه
لا يعلم لا يعمل كما ينبغي بالفعل جاء عام
2018 وفي هذا العام اتهمتها وزاره العدل
الامريكيه مع شريكها بسلسله من الجرائم
هومز اعترفت بارتكاب اخطاء لكنها انكرت
وبشده ارتكاب اي جرائم اليوم لم يتبقى لها
اي طريقه اخر تتبع سوى ذلك الذي سينقلها
الى السجن بعدما يقرب من عشرين عاما من
تاسيسها
لشركه لشركه
[موسيقى]
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات